why is Hollywood so difficult to pitch
the biggest thing is
it's expensive to do a project so the
risks are gargantuan you know we joke
about trying to pitch to somebody who
has the power to say maybe
and it's just I mean we find it hard
enough to sell a book
and when you're talking about even a
small film much less of a
big film they're just one mistake your
career is pretty much defined well it's
not upward until you're established so I
will say the upside of this is yes it's
O has been hard I don't think that's
changed from my dad's time or the
generation the thing that was great
during the studio system which predates
my father is that they ha it was like
you were hired and you were guaranteed
work you were under contract everybody
is freelance now
um and I'm talking about people above
the line I'm not you know the unions you
know they're always going to work people
in post-production like my brother who
owns his own company they're always
going to work
um I I think
the good news is that I mentioned Apple
earlier Apple Hulu Netflix when they
come out of this problem which they
inevitably will Amazon they're providing
new markets and new places and they're
you still have to have someone go in
with you who's
I think the trick is to go in with
somebody that they want to be in
business with and that's true in any
business I think now then then there's
also the the idea that
everybody that you're pitching to for
the most part consider themselves an
expert I will say that in television now
whatever form streaming Network that the
producer has less power than that than
in movies because as the Director does
because most directors in television are
hired it's the writer who has the power
finally and especially the showrunner
yeah and and that's a good thing and I
think
you know
sure if I'm pitching a group of
Hollywood Executives versus let's say a
group of Auto Executives is my pitching
style the same I know you gave the story
of the the Hawaiian shirts and maybe
maybe not showing the same respect but
um but let's suppose I'm showing them
respect I come in dressed appropriately
is the style any different
well there there are areas that are very
similar and areas that are not I think
the expectations are different for the
the two environments but but in each
case it's
we'll start with
First Impressions the way you walk into
a room is gargantuan it's like by the
time the doorknob is being turned you're
already you're
being evaluated
there was a an incredible research study
where they looked at music students
who were doing recitals and the first
thing they looked at was how do they
walk on stage
now in this study
on when you're when they bring in test
audience if
test audiences for sitcoms and they had
their holding dials if you turn them
this way we like it this way we don't
like it and the more I turn the more I
like it or don't and it's continuous
that's what they were using to evaluate
and the way they walked on right away
huge
and it lasted for several minutes the
effects of it somebody walks in kind of
mousy doesn't make eye contact they walk
in with shoulder back big difference
before they play a note
they also looked at when they screwed up
if they reacted badly if they're playing
in
or
you know I just loved who cares big
difference in terms of a big dip if you
show it
so those things start to matter simple
things like eye contact
gargantuan again if you're dealing with
one person as sort of a rule from the
research fifty percent eye contact is
good
if you're looking at somebody a hundred
percent of the time it's a lab
experiment and we're waiting for them to
tear the Wings off the Flies
um if they never look then it's what's
the matter with this person it's kind of
creepy if you have a group of people
you look at everyone you make sure even
if you're looking at the cheese a little
more
the person in the corner that you never
look at because you know he's an
underling well later when they have a
meeting and talk about you is going to
skunk you because you insulted them so
that starts to make a difference all
these things start to make a difference
whether it's in Hollywood or whether
it's in business uh yeah now the you
were asking why is a Hollywood pit so
difficult again
um
you start off with the idea of you
should have an original idea
but not too original
because if nobody's ever done it there's
a skepticism of this is such a great
idea in a hundred years how come
nobody's you know this is a losing idea
so you have to tread very lightly here
and again
how much confidence there's there's a
there's a Continuum of confidence to
arrogance to fear and you have to find a
really comfortable place along there to
do it now another thing tell me when you
want me to stop because this this can go
on for a while but
um
I think oh I just had one thought a
gender confidence Styles and I don't
mean to go too much how do you mean
female director if if a woman is is too
confident do you think maybe she'd be
seen as a little aggressive I think
that's changed I I I would agree with
Jeffrey that it's changing but for
openers remember that the gender issue
is from both sides
does a woman walk in with an expectation
that I'm not going to be taken as
seriously or I have to prove myself
harder
that's an issue that you may or may not
have and again the people on the other
side now it's interesting because
there's a phenomenon called
stereotypical threat
and again they do studies where if
um white and black kids take the same
exam
and they're asked to indicate their race
on the paper black students will do
worse than white students in a math test
if they're asked at the end that
difference is washed out if it's whites
and Asians the Asians will do better if
they're asked those things at the
beginning not at the end so people walk
in thinking I'm how am I going to be
looked at
and so if you're a woman and you have
total confidence in yourself you're
still aware that the way you're looked
at
you bring you know what are you bringing
in there with you do I have to do more
because
Etc et cetera et cetera we bring issues
in with us yeah but then there's there's
just I'm sorry just one more big
overriding idea about about in general
is that there's an expectation when you
walk in to give a pitch that you should
be pretty good at this because you've
had time to prepare
and you're an expert in what you're
doing so you should be dazzling
that's kind of a heavy responsibility to
walk in with it's you know people people
say to me sometimes when I have to get
up and talk in front of a group I'm
scared pointless but if I'm asked
answering questions to the same group
I'm really comfortable and again it's
the idea of expectation if you've had
time to prepare a you you should be an
expert or why are you up there and then
if you're an expert and you've had time
to prepare you better have something
pretty good for us which is different
than just being asked off the cuff so
again if you're if you're in the middle
of a pitch meeting and somebody says you
know you know I like your idea it's very
nice but we just got this novel would
you be interested in doing it what would
you do with it that's sometimes easier
to do than a pitch you brought in
because you don't have the expectation
of you've prepared this already this
better be good
does that make sense it does I also
think that it depends on what level in
any business you're in I mean if you're
Shonda rhymes and you walk into a room
you were asking about women so arguably
the most successful
female show runner maybe in the top 10
of all time
because show running is a relatively new
phenomenon
and now they come to her and she decides
if she'll do it or not but if you read
about her and you read about the
struggles she had not only as a woman
but as a black woman
it it she really had to work her way up
and um the thing I would add to all of
this which was great is that what I've
found when I've been pitched to because
I've produced things you know film and
um and theater it's all the same thing
is
you've got to be yourself if you try to
come in with a
kind of false
self you know if you're presenting a
persona
that'll turn people off if you're not if
you just be who you are and not
everybody has to be
you know I love that little impression
Peter did of the L theater graduate but
you know it's like some people we heard
this from interviews in the book some
people are quiet but people hear them
you know I mean I I personally think
that sometimes people who are quiet and
thoughtful are much more effective
than people who are like look what I've
got and you know you've never seen
anything like this before and and by the
way here's a lot of paperwork for you to
sign and you know
um I think you just have to be who you
are
um and one of the producers in the book
who started her career with Bonnie Raitt
about money rate Bonnie Hunt Bonnie Ray
would have been nice too
um but uh and she met Bonnie Ray at his
second City and a bunny bunny haunted
second City and she said that the thing
that she learned at right away was just
to come in and you don't have to you
never start with look what I've got for
you today
start with finding out who they are
improv a little don't don't you know
um this is this is um in in Japan which
we have in the book is it'll take days
before they want to hear what you have
you know they want to see who you are
um we could do better at that you know
everybody's in such a I worked in Canada
for a number of years and there's less
money and
but the quality is excellent
and they take time you know they take
time to get to know you you want to know
who you're working with the real person
I think that goes back to the JJ Abrams
quote you know
so yeah all those things are really
really important what Peter's talking
about but if you're not who you if
you're not
if you're not really the person that you
are if you bring some phony fake person
in
you're not going to sell them anything
and you know this you've heard this a
thousand times I'm sure
what if you bring a better version of
yourself
well that's always good well you know I
I think a big part of it you said no
jokes said that you go I was exactly I
was asking for a friend
I mean you know a big part of the
problem is
we've talked to people who have a
background both in acting and improv and
they are wonderful in a room there just
couldn't be any comfortable here
and there are other people who say you
know I'm a writer because I like to sit
by myself and cogitate
and I'm not comfortable with a lot of
other people and then I have to leave my
room and go in front of a room of people
and talk to them
and I think again as Jeffrey's saying is
you have to do a little bit of know
thyself and say all right I can be quiet
and still get my idea of course
and I can show the gravitas in my work
or the comedy but I can do it low-key
and I can do a lot of letting my work
speak for me
and if I try and act like I'm a stand-up
all of a sudden when that doesn't that
doesn't work well no but we also ran
across some interesting research
where they looked at the question of do
in do extroverts make better sales
people
and
what they found was no
does that mean introverts are better no
they they said there's a group in the
middle they refer to as ambiverts and
again they said that the problem that
extroverts have is it's all about them
so sometimes they don't get to the
important points they're pitching
because they're still talking about
themselves
introverts sometimes is navigated out
ambiverts have a better idea they tend
to be more empathic and figure out what
your needs are and be able to cater to
them more directly and to get out the
stuff that's important to them